so in the few moments before pilate the
roman governor of judea
hands jesus over to the jews to be
crucified
there is a strange exchange what happens
in which pilate
offers to release a prisoner and
thinking that maybe the crowd will ask
for jesus
instead the crowd asks for barabbas
and the entire narrative is set up in a
way that seems to
create a relationship opposition between
these two characters
one is jesus and the other is barabbas
an insurrectionist and a murderer
uh criminal and so the crowd asks for
barabas and so i want to look at
what is going on in this story why this
opposition is set up
what it can tell us about who christ is
and also what it can tell us about today
and some of the things we're seeing in
the world happen especially in the
united states with the protests and the
riots
how this seems to be related to the
relationship between jesus and
[Music]
barabbas
this is jonathan pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
so we read in the gospel of saint luke
pilate summoned the chief priests and
the rulers
and the people and said to them you
brought this man to me as one who
incites the people to rebellion and
behold
having examined him before you i have
found no guilt
in this man regarding the charges which
you make against him
no nor has herod for he sent him back to
us and behold
nothing deserving of death has been done
by him
therefore i will punish him and release
him
now he was obliged to release to them
at the feast one prisoner
but they cried out together to together
saying away with this man
and released for us barabbas he was
one who had been thrown into prison for
an insurrection made in the city
and for murder pilate wanted to release
jesus
address to them again but they kept on
calling out saying crucify him crucify
him
and he said to them the third time why
what evil has this man done
i have founded him no guilt demanding
death therefore i will punish him
and release him but they were insistent
with loud voices asking
that he be crucified and their voices
began to prevail
and pilate pronounced sentence that
their demand be granted and he released
the man they were asking for
who had been thrown into prison for
insurrection and murder but he delivered
jesus to their will
in another version of the text it also
says
that uh when pilate saw that he
accomplished nothing in trying to
get the crowd to want to release jesus
that
he saw that he couldn't accomplish
anything and saw that a riot was about
to start
and that's when he washed his hands that
famous gesture and said
i am innocent of this man's blood see to
see to that
yourselves um there are some really
interesting aspects about this
relationship first we need to say a few
things about
barabbas and the situation that was
happening as if you don't know a little
your bible history
you need to understand that in the time
of jesus the
israel judea was ruled over by rome rome
had taken over
and they were ruling the jews the jews
were known
in that time to be a rowdy bunch in the
sense that they didn't accept
the rule of rome peacefully
in part because rome didn't also
understand
the jewish religion and tended to ask
the jews to do
things like you know you know offer
sacrifice to the emperor
there were stories of the roman emperor
trying to put
roman statues in the temple kind of
pagan statues
they were used to this this the romans
were used to this kind of weird
you know mixed paganism that the jews
refused
and so because of that there were
insurrections there had been
insurrections before
of course the famous insurrection of the
maccabees in which
they tried to fight off the the
hellenistic rulers
um and in that time also there were
insurrectionists there were zealots
they called them people who wanted the
uh
the jews to fight against the roman
domination
and so in this situation what you have
is you have
a man barabbas who was part of this
insurrection
and was had murdered people during the
desire to raise up and to take power
from their roman overlords so in the
story of the situation where the
roman governor was supposed to release a
prisoner traditionally
uh because it was the feast of passover
and
here is this choice which is presented
to the people and in one text it seems
like it's the people calling and
other versions it seems like it's pilot
who's proposing these two
opposites for the people to choose from
a fascinating detail to notice is that
the name barabbas means son of the
father
but not only that in some early versions
of the gospel of matthew
origen talks about how in some of the
early versions then
barabbas's name is jesus and so his name
is jesus
barabbas and then in some versions of
the the gospels
you see that pilate says jesus the king
of the jews or jesus the messiah
and then there's this other character
barabbas who in some versions of the
early texts
were named was named jesus now they took
out the name
jesus or maybe it was inserted by other
people by heretics who knows it doesn't
matter but what's interesting to notice
is that
there is definitely set up whether it's
by the name or just by the situation
a parallel between these two sides
between jesus
and this this character barabbas what i
think
it is referring to is that i think that
in
christianity the story of the gospel is
also kind of setting up a pattern
and is setting up a pattern which will
manifest itself
in the church itself will manifest
itself in history will become
a you know will set up a pattern for
reality and
there is in the story in the gospel
there are some what you could call
fail-safes in the story
the gospel story um one of the
one of the re the things that that
characterize christianity is the fact
that
christ is always moving towards the
margin
he's always moving towards the poor and
so he
you know of course there's the
beatitudes where he says blessed are the
are the poor blessed are the meek and
and tends to want to bring the blessing
to the poor he also talks about things
like the lost sheep
about how the shepherd who goes out and
moves all the way and finds
leaves the the flock and goes all the
way out to find that
lost sheep and bring the lost sheep back
and so he
hangs out with tax collectors hangs out
with prostitutes
hangs out with people of bad life and
the reason why he's doing that is
because
he is the light which is moving out into
death
and so his whole story is about about
that which is above
going all the way down to the bottom
filling up the world with light and so
in order to do that he has to go all the
way to the edge
when the pharisees ask him why he's
hanging out with tax collectors
and people that have a bad life he
answers
you know you don't send a doctor to
heal healthy people you send a doctor to
heal the sick and that's the whole
notion of the incarnation
is that the light comes down and fills
up the world
but in that story there is of course a
possible danger right there is a danger
in emphasizing
the relationship of god or the high
which comes down into the low
there is the danger of let's say
seeing value in the margin
in itself or seeing a
seeing the value of the margin almost in
a kind of revolutionary
manner and we've seen that in the story
of christianity
as christianity let's say moves away
from its own
central principles it can tend to move
towards
revolutionary thinking that's why the
french revolution
uh marxist revolution all of these
revolutions happen
in the story of christianity in a
post-christian world or in a world where
christianity is losing its grip even in
the things like the peasant revolts
already during the time
of the the radical reformation and in
other moments in the story of
christianity you can see how there's a
temptation
to see this let's say notion of
the god coming to the lowly that god
manifesting himself in a way that brings
that which is low
kind of lifts it up into himself i
talked about this in um
in a recent video that we could see
that we could interpret it almost as a
revolutionary manner especially
understanding that at the time that
christ came into the world there was
already that zealot thinking
in in the the jewish culture and so
it seems like in the story of christ
there are some fail-safes
to prevent the the story from being
interpreted that way
or to stop the that type of
that type of pattern from manifesting
itself legitimately within the christian
story
and this seems to be one of them there's
a few others we'll look at them
so what we have is basically we have a
set up where pilate is saying
choose your messiah which is your
messiah is it
this character who is it who leads an
insurrection against rome
who's a criminal who is murdered who has
done all these things in the desire
to achieve his political goal or is it
this character who is
teaching about a kingdom but a different
kind of
kingdom right the kingdom of god which
manifests itself in the heart of people
which transforms from the inside and
transformed by creating holy people
and that is and those waves will
transform the world
right become a tree so that the birds
can land in your branches
you know that you need to not judge your
brother but to take
the the the beam out of your own eye
all of these types of of teachings that
christ is giving
is about this transformation from within
which then ripples out into the outside
whereas the
the the insurrectionist is one who
believes that
transformation needs to happen in a
political sphere it needs to happen in
the social sphere
and from the outside and so you
basically have a setup
where pilate is asking which is which
jesus do you want which son of the
father do you want
and do you want this this son of the
father the one who transformed from the
inside
or this son of the father the one who
wants to transform from the outside and
transform do
in a political and and a uh you know in
a violent manner and so
it's very fascinating to watch now there
are other moments in the story of jesus
where he appeals to the same pattern
um where he appeals to the pattern of
being careful not
to see the social aspect of the teaching
of christ
the uh what could be interpreted in
terms of a political aspect
what we could call today the social
justice aspect
to not see it as the most important to
not see it
as the highest value but rather
understand that
the highest value must be god the
highest value must be worship
the highest value must be this communion
and
focusing towards that which is beyond us
and then
from there will come the social aspects
of the christian message but
if you flip it upside down and you put
the social above
the spiritual if you put the political
above
the worship then things go completely
off
that is there in the choice between
barabbas and jesus but it's also
in the ver one of the very rare times
where jesus
actually uh interacts with judas jesus
doesn't interact with judas
very much in scripture one of the places
where jesus
interacts with judas is in a story where
christ is is in a home
and there's a sinful woman who comes in
and she wipes jesus's feet
with this very very precious perfume and
she pours this perfume on his feet and
she
kind of washes his feet there's all
kinds of symbolism happening
in that situation but we won't go into
all the symbolism but
we mostly hope it's mostly important to
understand that she has this gesture
of attention to his feet and this
gesture of worship towards him
towards himself and what you see in that
situation
is barabbas uh complains
and brava says you know we could have
used
that perfume sold it and given the money
to the poor
and christ's answer is very telling he
says
you know the poor will always be with
you but
you know the bridegroom is here for a
very short time and so
he's saying get your priorities in order
you need worship comes first attention
to
the incarnation attention to christ to
the anointed one
attention to the god man comes first
and then comes the other part and he's
not of course not saying you shouldn't
help the poor you shouldn't be the poor
christ has often said that we need to do
that
but he's saying the poor will always be
there you need to get your attention
in line and what's fascinating about
this is
also it says in the text that the reason
why judas was saying that
wasn't really because he wanted to help
the poor
but it was because he was a thief and he
was he
he carried the money purse for the
disciples and he would go
and take the money out for himself
and so it's very fascinating to
understand if you understand the pattern
what it leads to and so when we look at
what has been happening um
in uh in the recent events let's say
with the protests and the riots in the
united states
i think it's very important to look at
the manner in which
the story was framed by some people now
in the weeks
that followed the death of george floyd
we started to see some images appear and
some suggestions we saw
you know father for example father james
martin catholic priest who is
extremely extremely liberal you know
probably one of the most vocally
liberal priests in the united states
comparing
uh floyd to jesus you also
saw um an article talking about the
crucifixion of george floyd
there are many many examples culminating
in
some images where you could see him
represented with a halo with
wings and with the halo kind of got more
and more
until finally it came down to
an actual icon where
an icon of the mother of god
placing you know with her dead son in
her inner arms
the face of jesus was replaced with a
portrait of george floyd
full on with the halo with the cross
and in the cross saying that is
i am god there it actually it is
the when you put those letters in
a halo that those letters means the one
that is that is
that is god himself and so this was the
epitome of course
of the situation but already you could
see some images appear of people
kneeling in front of images of george
floyd of course
it was very ambiguous because it was
kind of like the blm kneeling
but nonetheless you see people you see
the images turned into shrines with
people kneeling
and so there really is this strange
almost deification
of george floyd and what's fascinating
about it is of course
the comparison between let's say george
floyd and christ not just the character
not just george floyd but george floyd
in
the context of black lives matter and in
the context
of the protests and in the context of
what became
a riots and also the taking over of
certain aspects of
the cities because of course you know mr
floyd it
it's very sad that he was that he had to
die that day was not
it was very unbearable to watch and it
was a
tragedy of course but
but george floyd was us obviously not
like christ george floyd was a
was a someone who was a convicted
criminal at
certain times in his life he was on
drugs at the time and it's the same with
several of the characters who have also
sparked other riots
in the consequence of george floyd
all those characters seems to have been
criminals or accused of criminal actions
in very suspicious situations with uh
you know with some very suspicious past
and so
it is very fascinating that there is a
comparison between
someone like george floyd and christ and
of course that comparison would not
be that big of a deal in the sense that
you could make a very slight comparison
in the sense of someone
who who died unjustly but it becomes a
bigger deal of course when you get to
an actual icon but not also because you
have to understand
the the comparison in the context of
insurrectional acts in the context of
revolutionary acts in the context of
riots and protests
and in the context of riots and protests
in the name
of the little ones in the name of the
poor
in the broadest sense in those that are
marginalized by society
you know and like i said this is where
it gets tricky to unto see the
difference between
christianity and a strange um
let's say perversion of the christian
ideal christianity which
wants to take care of those who are poor
and marginalized and those who are on
the edge who wants to
reach in and you know help them to
to participate in you know in the
kingdom of god
the difference between that and what
we're seeing happening with buildings
on fire and this revolutionary action
and like i said
we always have to remember that the
situation was similar to what was
happening in the time
of jesus which is that the rome was an
oppressive power
and the jews were persecuted were under
the boot of the roman
authorities and there were insurrections
and riots and
and rebellions against the authorities
but jesus never
actually spoke up against that
jesus never never gave political
a political drive towards what was going
to happen
he was going to transform rome christ
was going to
not only transform but take over rome
but he was going to do it in a different
manner he was going to do it
from the inside out rather than from
political action and social action which
usually
doesn't alleviate the problem but just
ends up replacing
one power by another
and this is of course where the story of
judas comes into mind is to remem
remember in the story of judas where his
desire
to help the poor because it was
presented as higher
than the desire to worship became
was actually a subterfuge for what he
really wanted
which was power and i think that we see
that that's what happened in
the revolutionary movements of the past
whether it be the french revolution or
the russian revolution
although it was presented in the guise
of helping the little ones
of helping the poor in the end what it
happened
what happened was a reversal a
new elite which was more violent
more cruel more controlling than the one
before
and uh was was actually that's a
controlling society with an iron fist
in a very perverse way and it seems like
with these these these requests to
to defund the police or to disband the
police to disband the current order
the breaking down of statues the
breaking down of order although it is
done
in the name of the little one because it
is seen as the highest value
because characters like george floyd who
you know you could say was unjustly
killed
was nonetheless not a holy man was not a
was not a saint was not someone who was
known for being
for being christ-like um and so
in that guys comes the flames comes the
revolution and the insurrection
um that is definitely not the message
that
christ has given and so i just wanted to
offer a little bit of reflection on the
subject
of course there would be much more to
say but i thought it was important to
talk about that as we see these protests
not lit up as we see the situation
not calm down we need to be able as
christians as people who are
looking at the story of christ to be
able to notice the difference and to
tell the difference
because for a very long time in certain
branches of christianity
christ is represented as a kind of
revolutionary figure
a figure that is presenting
some kind of social justice change
whereas i don't believe that's what
christ was doing
the change the justice the peace comes
from an inner transformation
of his saints and a communion of love
between people
not a pointing of fingers and a finding
the guilty one
canceling them getting rid of them and
uh demonizing
all the all the people who aren't part
of your group so that is what i wanted
to bring
to you today as usual i want to thank
everybody
for your attention thank everybody for
your support um
and i will talk to you very soon as you
know everything i do here on the
symbolic world is thanks to your support
there are many ways which you can show
your support of course please share
these videos
as i'm talking about these subjects you
know for certain that
i will not be on the good side of the
youtube algorithm so please share
subscribe do all the things that people
on youtube ask you to do
but you can also support directly by
buying some merchandise or
by you know going onto my website the
symbolicworld.com
support and you'll also find ways to
support me there
and as usual i want to thank you for
your attention thank you for giving me
the opportunity to do this and i'll talk
to you very soon bye-bye